les vignerons sont de mauvaise humeur
les slogans inventés par la publicité
visant à limiter la consommation
d'alcool se transforme distille en
campagne anti 20 la confédération
nationale des caves particulières vient
de riposter en lançant à son tour
encontre slogan un vert ouvre la voie
trois verres donne la joie et c'est vrai
qu'à vos en beaujolais l'ambiance de la
cave de ce charmant village n'était pas
à la morosité
mais au delà du sacro-saint canon de 12
heures nous avons recueilli quelques
réactions forcément bien mais aussi
concise un peu de figures du monde en
parlant de r que ça fini dit est-ce que
c'est 300 qui dit c'est un désagrément
rien alors pense là dedans qui a
quelques mauvaises intentions vis-à-vis
c'est intolérable nous engage à produire
bon et mieux pour pouvoir mieux les
pentes et et puis on s'en va à
l'étranger andy dans les fentes air un
peu de bois
vous pourriez pas président que deux
voire trois verres de bougerait c'est
quand même un produit qui est tout à
fait naturel au mieux voire probable
qu'il ait eu boire un verre d'alcool
fort qui est à ce titre nous sommes pas
chargés nous deux directeurs de
conscience en face à l'égoïsme tout
simplement nous disons nous que
la consommation normale du bon vin ne
peut pas faire tous les cataclysmes
entre et tous les cas tu as qui dans ton
semble menacée alors qu'ils viennent
voir ici les gens ont des figures
l'enterrement c'est un peu à peu un dc
qu'on en serait à mon sens parce que
tout le monde sait que la france est une
vieille nation viticole c'est une
vieille civilisation qui vise à turin
c'est elle qui nous a dans certains cas
réconforter exemple est pratiquement 25
14 ou sans aucun doute mais sans aucun
doute la guerre n'aurait pas été gagnée
safran de plaies de pinard
c'est à dire trouver du réconfort dans
nos moments terriblement on souffrait
terriblement dans la chair et non et
dans les dom et puis on ne surmonter
parce que précisément on avait acquis
avec le vin une bonne morale et
solidement tout dire et qu'on avait le
courage même de mourir ma voix ils iront
chanter avec ça au moins les choses
pateras pelloux incident
[Musique]